un jeune virtuose sur la scène de
l'équinoxe accompagné de l'orchestré
national des pays de la loire le
pianiste français alexandre kantorow
vainqueur du prestigieux concours
tchaïkovski en 2019 répète un mouvement
du concerto pour piano numéro 2 de franz
liszt
à quelques pas de là à la chapelle des
rédemptoristes c'est un trio qui
s'apprête à interpréter les oeuvres du
compositeur
enfin prodi hongroise danse des morts
entre autres une sélection entre ombre
et lumière
toujours été tiraillé entre
entre
incertaine attrait pour le charme la
séduction les prouesses facile quelque
part et en même temps des questions
essentielles et une vocation religieuse
donc qu'il a jonglé entre les deux toute
sa vie et finalement c'est un peu le
sombre et le religieux et l'intérieur
qui a fini par par l'emporter orchestre
une formation plus restreinte une
volonté de puiser dans la diversité du
répertoire de liste
on imagine toujours lisse comme cette
espèce de pianiste planétaire ce qui
l'était aussi mais ça a été un immense
compositeur qui a composé des pages
religieuse des leaders pourvoi de la
musique de chambre des choses avec
orchestre donc c'est quelqu'un de très
ouvert de l'ordre aussi très ouvert sur
la modernité donc effectivement je vais
à chaque fois montré des facettes très
ouverte de ce grand génie
on
fabuleux magique magistral tout
simplement les gens réagissent
formidablement c'est magnifique stylé
mais très très bien joué vraiment plein
d'émotions
génial
en clôture du festival ce mardi la scène
de l'équinoxe sera un peu moins bondée
avec le récital du pianiste soliste
bertrand chamayou le récital une forme
de concerts en solo dont franz liszt a
été le précurseur